うみゃ～
よぅ　おれだ　はじめしゃちょーだ
へゃ　よう、俺だ。へゃ
今日はお前らにすごげぇことを見せるぜ。へゃ
へゃ。へゃ。へゃ
ぐ、ぐ、ぐーを出してみるぜ
ぱー出してみるぜ
両手で、ぱーだぜ
へゃ
手、組んでみるぜ
へゃ　へゃ
と、言う訳で今日は、
こちらを準備したぜ。へゃ
見てこれ
クリスタルだぜ。へゃ
マジッククリスタル、ライトブルー
大人も子供もみんな夢中！
１０日で育つクリスタル
いろんな色があるぜ。へゃ
作り方、クリスタルパウダーをお湯で溶かして
なんか、えうｆげるいｇｈ
楽しいぜ！
へゃ
俺の夢は、甲子園。へゃ
グリーンダヨ！！
へゃ
入れ物だぜ
へゃ。へゃ。へゃ
これが、土台だぜ。へゃ
これ、危なそうな粉だぜ。へゃ。へゃ。へゃ
１００℃のお湯にクリスタルの粉を入れて、混ぜて、フタをするぜ
へゃ
木の棒でかき混ぜて、後は、スロットを回しに行くぜ
へゃ。へゃ
ていうことで、この中に一時間。へゃ　放置し
常温になった　へゃ　液の中にクリスタルの土台を
へゃ　へゃ　へゃ
これだけたくさんの　へゃ
クリスタルを　へゃ　いれて
早速ここにあるクリスタルを全部混ぜて
今回は。へゃ巨大なクリスタルを作りたいぜ。へゃ
ふ、、ふ、、へゃ。へゃ
開封してるぜ。へゃ。へゃ。開封。へゃ
とりあえず、全部、開けたぜ。へゃ
お湯を沸騰させるぜ。へゃ
あ！こんにちは！
と言うわけで、この中に200ｃｃ
熱！！
あ、待って
200ｃｃを8回入れていきます
200ｃｃいきます
200ｃｃってのは、どこでわかるの？
あー　ここね　OK
いくよ200ｃｃ　はーい
入るよ～
あちぃぃ～！
熱い湯気が～
一個目
ふうん～二個目
あっつい！！待って！！
ほんとにやばい！
熱い熱い！
待って俺ほんとにやけどしちゃう
熱い！
俺思った
タライじゃ深すぎるな
タライだと深すぎるので、バケツでもう一回やります。
200ｃｃのお湯を8回分いれなきゃいけないっていうことは
もう先に計算して
8回分の水を全部やかんに入れておきましょう
１００℃にしてバケツにそのまま入れれるという
非常に効率のよいことが出来ます
うわ、いい具合じゃない
たぶんこれぐらい
１、２，３
４，５，６，７，８、
OK~です～
たぶん沸騰して少し、少なくなるので
少し気持ち多めに入れておきました。
ファイヤー！　ゴットファイヤー！
頼む見せてくれお前の本気
もうガンガン入れていきます。
うわ～すごい色だ
あーーー！間違って入れちゃった袋ごと
ふ、、ふ、、ふ
OK,OKたぶんOKです
で、このあとしっかり蓋をしまっ
フタ、フタ、あ！
ベイブレードやっててよかった
完璧なフタがありました
これで６０分待つらしいです
これ、一時間待って常温に戻します
タオルとかを巻いて、ゆっくり温度が下がるようにします
よしOK
一時間待ちます！
さてそろそろよいのではないでしょ・・・
あ、あれ？
まだか。。。まだ熱い、まだ熱いぞ
うわ～ちょっとまだだな
うわ～なんかゴミが～　あ、そういうことか
ゴミが付着するとダメだからフタをしめろってことね
はい、常温になったので、土台を入れます
はい、いい感じにまとめました
これちょうどいいサイズじゃない
このバケツに入るくらいのサイズなんで
むずいよむずいよ
いや、これ、まってガチムチじゃん
え、ちょ、いくよ
あ、手が　手が死ぬ
うあああぁぁぁああ～！
で、この中に、種ですね、クリスタルの種をいれて
一日蓋をして待った後に
十日間待つと
上手くいけばだよ、上手くいけば
超巨大なクリスタルができているというわけでございます
いろんな色混ぜたんで
何色になるかってわかんないので、
すごい楽しみです
うふ♪
ひとまず粉入れますね
OK~
では、たぶん十日後ぐらいに動画を出すと思うんですけども
それで、果たして・・・
十日後の動画で、果たしてこの
レインボー巨大クリスタルはどうなっているのか
是非　お楽しみにお待ち下され
ていうわけで、十日後の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃーな！
さて、東京いってきます